[Musica]
nonostante
insomma io vado spesso in giro a
raccontare un pezzetto della mia storia
di vita l'emozione è sempre tantissima
infatti chiedo scusa se magari in
garbuio qualcosa farò degli errori
madornali però sono veramente sempre
tanto emozionata perché comunque quando
si racconta una parte della propria vita
che ti vede che ti vede lottare una
parte della vita dove comunque di vedere
mare ecco oggi parliamo tanto il tema di
questo the dix remare
diciamo che io l'ho sentito subito
affine a
a quello che è stato il mio percorso di
vita quello di fare tanta fatica per
uscire da una situazione di stallo per
venir fuori da una situazione difficile
ecco oggi quello che vi racconto è
è una testimonianza quindi nulla di
grandi discorsi preparati anche perché
non fanno per me però ecco spero di di
di darvi un
un piccolo spunto di essere un po un
piccolo esempio come qualcun altro lo è
stato per me ai tempi e ecco io spero di
esserlo per qualcun altro oggi io nasco
37 anni fa
nasco con una genesi a congenita di
femore e perone che detto in un gergo
accessibile
nasco senza la gamba sinistra o comunque
con un pezzetto di gamba completamente
va informata
diciamo che quindi il mio percorso di
vita sia adattato sin da subito a vivere
con
diciamo con una mancanza di un arto è
sicuramente un un percorso diverso ecco
io la parola diverso la uso spessissimo
al contrario di quanti possano pensare
che magari è brutto usare il termine
diverso io invece penso che sia una cosa
assolutamente normalissima
anzi spero che sia un tabù che crolli
perché diversi siamo tutti quindi
assolutamente è un termine che secondo
me varese un po più accessibile
quindi ho sicuramente un percorso di
vita un po diverso ma diciamo che grazie
al sostegno familiare
e delle amicizie insomma di chi mi sta
vicino comunque ho cercato di fare
sempre insomma una una vita abbastanza
dignitosa una vita abbastanza felice
sorridente
fino a fino a un certo punto c'è un
momento in cui io sentivo forte questa
idea di volermi riscattare io ho
cominciato a vivere insomma l'idea che
la vita mi avesse tolto qualcosa io in
qualche modo devo riprendermela
era diventato quasi un pallino no nella
testa quindi questa questa forte idea
questa forte voglia di riscatto
sapevo di avere delle energie che da
qualche modo che in guarda qualche parte
dove incanalare ma non riuscivo mai a
imboccare la strada giusta
finché
quando si dice non tutte le disgrazie
vengono per nuocere
in seguito a una serie di interventi
perché io quotidianamente diciamo che ho
una protesi quando il moncone me lo
permette non è quando lo porti poi per
37 anni un po ci sono delle difficoltà e
quindi quando possono la uso
finché insomma circa otto anni fa
dieci anni fa e b delle forti difficoltà
dei nuovi interventi e mi dissero di
dovermi ricoverare in una clinica
riabilitativa in questa clinica
e nato diciamo il solo l'idea però è
nathalie
questa questo questo amore per lo sport
paralimpico perché perché in questa
clinica io ho trovato chi ha saputo far
bene il suo lavoro perché credo che un
lavoro di di cura come quello di del
fisioterapista che all'epoca mi segui
deve essere fatto non solo della della
cura riabilitativa di per sé ma io un
lavoro di cura lo vedo completo di non
so di stimoli di dare una persona le
motivazioni giuste per andare avanti di
creare delle opportunità
e all'epoca quella persona fece con me
questo lavoro molto molto bene
incanalando mie dicendomi che insomma
c'era la possibilità di intraprendere
alcuni sport paralimpici e perché ma io
non ci avessi mai pensato io non ho
saputo rispondere a questa domanda in
realtà l'epoca anche se poi ad oggi
con una maturità anche diversa
mi sono resa conto che in effetti
c'era ancora troppo poco intorno a noi
di sport paralimpici
se ne parlava poco e le paralimpiadi in
tv erano ancora uno scenario
lontanissimo hanno ultimamente iniziato
a dare molto di più alla tv hanno
ultimamente iniziato a parlare molto di
più degli sport paralimpici
io credo ci sia ancora tanta strada da
fare a riguardo ma grazie a dio siamo
insomma sulla strada giusta
quindi di lì dopo un mese e mezzo di
ricovero tornai a casa e cominciai a
chiedere in giro qualcuno che sapesse
indirizzarmi su qualche sport da poter
fare mi dicono che a termoli
io sono molisana di campobasso vivo a
lanciano
all'epoca lavoravo a termoli e mi
dissero che a termoli c'era una squadra
di pallacanestro in carrozzina no io la
pallacanestro non la potevo vedere
neanche lontanamente proprio uno sport
che non si avvicinava per nulla ha
insomma a quello che potesse minimamente
piacermi però hanno insistito talmente
tanto è un giorno andai a vedere un
allenamento
un giorno andai a vedere un allenamento
e mi resi conto di quanto era difficile
gestire la palla la carrozzina guardare
l'avversario giocare di squadra far
arrivare la palla al canestro di lidi si
va beh sarà che la pallacanestro mi
piace però questa è una figata perché è
difficilissima quindi le cose difficili
un po ti stimolano perché diventa poi
una sfida con testi soligo ci voglio
provare quel giorno mi sono seduta in
carrozzina io non mi sono più alzata
quindi diciamo che la pallacanestro è
stato il mio primo sport
di lì ho iniziato con le competizioni
regionali nazionali dopodiché arrivata
la prima convocazione in nazionale e ad
oggi sono un atleta della nazionale
italiana femminile di pallacanestro in
carrozzina
grazie e diciamo che poi pian piano
mi sono grazie insomma al all'entrata in
questo mondo ho aperto molto di più le
vedute ho cominciato anche solo per
curiosità a fare una serie di
sperimentazioni sportive
finché arriva qualcuno che mi propone
la bicicletta ma io insomma l'ho anche
guardato un po male per dire ma la
bicicletta con una gamba sola
poi io che su una bici non ci sono mai
salita neanche la piccola quindi non
sapevo proprio neanche tenere
l'equilibrio
insomma un tarlo che mia vita stava per
qualche notte finché ho detto vabbè ci
voglio provare quindi saliamo in bici
non vi nego che
e stato difficilissimo come avete visto
dal video io ho dovuto montare le
rotelle come bambini quindi
ho iniziato con una bici insomma così da
battaglia ha montato le rotelle ho
cercato di capire come si reggesse
l'equilibrio e ho iniziato a togliere
una rotella a togliere la seconda finché
le abbiamo tolte è iniziato insomma il
mio viaggio in bici
non vi nego che è stata durissima perché
ci sono state tante cadute degli
incidenti ci sono state tante volte in
cui ho detto forse non è forse non è il
caso
lì ha giocato un ruolo importantissimo
il mio compagno che mi ha sempre
sostenuta perché vivi faccio un piccolo
scoop ma quel fisioterapista che seppe
fare benissimo il suo lavoro lo ha fatto
così tanto bene che oggi è diventato il
mio compagno di vita il padre di mio
figlio e questo insomma è un po per
sottolineare quanto importante il ruolo
della famiglia quanto è importante il
ruolo di chi ci sta accanto nel
sostenerci momenti difficili nel
sostenerci momenti in cui magari a noi
crolla un po qualcosa perché
non è che insomma siamo siamo super eroi
quindi
l'altro importante importantissimo nella
reni soprattutto in una relazione
credo sia veramente fondamentale quindi
insomma grazie a lui siamo saliti anche
in bici e sono arrivate le maglie
tricolori siano arrivati i campionati
italiani delle coppe europa e grazie a
dio anche linea andata benissimo
dopo di che però la bici deciso di
abbandonarla deciso di abbandonarla
perché fisicamente non mi guardate
adesso perché ho partorito ciò tanti
chili su ma vi garantisco che era un
atleta o comunque lo sono però devo
ancora tornare in forma
però insomma per costituzione fisica era
vedevo un po più conforme a me alla mia
fisicità l'hand bike che si pedala con
le braccia perché comunque con la
pallacanestro io ero molto allenata con
la parte superiore del corpo per cui
diciamo che quella è stata sempre da
quando ho cominciato a seguire zanardi
ho detto mi piacerebbe pedalare con una
handbike
non so se voi sapete però che i costi di
questi mezzi sono inaccessibili
ad oggi comprare una carrozzina
pallacanestro comprare un handbike
comprare una bici adattata e veramente
un delirio perché sono dei prezzi
altissimi e purtroppo questa cosa la
sottolineo perché spero che arrivi alle
orecchie di qualcuno
le istituzioni non fanno ancora
abbastanza al riguardo quindi
diciamo che era stato sempre un mio
sogno
finché non l'ho incontrato alex zanardi
non so se voi conoscete il progetto
obiettivo 3 ma è un progetto che dà
l'opportunità a persone con disabilità
di approcciarsi agli a degli sport
mettendo a disposizione dei mezzi
quindi grazie a lui ho avuto nel bike e
da lì è iniziato il mio viaggio con con
l'hand bike e ad oggi pedalò nel team
zanardi
è un carissimo e fortissimo pensiero
oggi va a lui che un anno dall'ultima
incidente quindi insomma e allora penso
di di avervi detto tutto dalla parte
sportiva ma mi manca la cosa credo più
importante e cioè che la mia medaglia
più grande e più valoroso è arrivata il
3 settembre del 2020 che a mio figlio ne
ha e spero allora ogni volta che mi si
chiede di raccontare insomma parte della
della mia vita
nonostante l'ansia nonostante l'emozione
lo faccio sempre tanto volentieri perché
io penso sempre a me e torno indietro a
me
dieci anni fa quando tutte queste cose
mi erano un po scure e e penso che se
qualcuno avesse raccontato un po di più
qualcuno avesse parlato un po di più
qualcuno se qualcuno avesse fatto vedere
un po di più probabilmente io avrei
intrapreso uno sport tanti e tanti anni
prima visto che comunque con questa
disabilità cina sco e quindi ecco spero
che questa sia sicuramente un'occasione
per per chi mi guarderà per voi che
siete qui di
di capire che
anche dietro insomma dietro una
disabilità c'è un grandissimo mondo
paralimpico
ci sono milioni di sport che danno la
possibilità alle persone di potersi
riscattare di poter fare
di poter fare tanto io dico sempre noi
siamo atleti a tutti gli effetti perché
in realtà siamo atleti quindi seppur con
una gamba in meno un braccio in meno non
vedenti
e qualsivoglia ma siamo pur sempre
atleti si fanno tanti sacrifici per di
per arrivare a certi livelli
così come li fa un'altra l'eta
normodotato ecco spero che la mia
testimonianza arriva alle orecchie di
tanti anche alle orecchie di chi magari
in questo momento pensa che non lo so è
successo qualcosa che non gli permette
di o pensa che quel limite sia
invalicabile ecco io lo so che è una
frase fatta che i limiti esistono solo
nella mente ma io ci credo veramente
perché per me è veramente così cioè il
limite è veramente solo mentale e e
penso e spero che tanti possano
continuare a remare seppur con tanta
fatica per venir fuori da una situazione
di stallo che a volte ci crea ci crea
veramente tanta tristezza o cicr e ci
potrebbe creare insomma tante difficoltà
quindi remate rimati tanto e se volete
qualcosa
lottate per che si può conquistare si
può fare tutto si può fare grazie